Musik Okay.
Nein, aber du siehst ihn doch nicht.
Nein, wir sehen uns, aber die Zuschauer nicht, die hören uns nur.
Ja, aber wir sehen uns nur und hören uns nicht.
Ach, krass.
Ja, das ist ja die Idee von Podcasting.
Ach, ich kenne das nur aus dem Radio, dass man sich auch hört die ganze Zeit. Nein, nein, nein, wir sehen uns nur. Du musst vielleicht dein Mikrofon vielleicht ein bisschen nach unten stellen. Da kannst du einfach hier in diesem... Oh, der Stefan hilft dir, der Gentleman. Der ist ja nett, dafür ist der, der fingert er gleich... Der fingert er gleich rum. So, aber es regnet draußen. Ah, Mensch, hier fliegen die Pointen durch die Luft. Man muss eigentlich nur seinen Beutel aufmachen und sie einfangen. Ähm, ja, perfekt. Genau, richtig, vermeide P-Laute, P-T-K sind ganz schlecht, ganz schlecht. Aber A-Laute. A-Laute sind, du hast ja wahrscheinlich eine professionelle Sprechausbildung, oder? Ne, ja, ich war mal kurz bei 1Live. Ah, da nimmt man ja viel mit, ne? Boah, sagst du in einem Nebensatz, ne, war kein Nebensatz, war ein Hauptsatz. Ja, du weisst auch nicht, wie viele Wochen oder Tage. Ich war auch mal ganz kurz bei 1Live. Ja, du auch? Und warum hat es bei dir nicht geklappt? Ich habe keine Lust mehr gehabt. Ich auch, ich bin nicht mehr hingegangen. Ich bin auch nicht mehr hingegangen. Vor allem, ich war dann so quasi, da haben die gesagt, ja, du kannst uns einfach hier abhängen und so. Aber es war alles so ein lockeres Verhältnis. Wann warst du denn da in welchem Jahr? Boah, weiß ich nicht, vor zwei Jahren, drei Jahren? Ich war 2012 da. Ich glaube, ich war 13 einfach. Ich war dann so, das Pound auf und die halt ein Jahr danach. Na, dann bin ich da hingegangen und dann hatten die nicht so viele Aufgaben für mich und ich bin auch zu verfaul, mir einfach selber Aussagen zu suchen. Und dann bin ich einfach nicht mehr gekommen und dann war irgendwann vorbei einfach. Nee, ich hatte am Anfang Ehrgeiz und dachte, ich schlag megageile Themen vor, hab ich auch vorgeschlagen, es war immer so. Hier, Themen hast du vorgeschlagen, was waren so deine Top-Themen? Kannst du noch was sagen? Was war 2012 hot? So, jetzt kommen die Top 27 der Themen von 2012! Nie genommen die nie genommen wurden. Also mein Top-Thema eins war, mein Themenvorschlag war Spielplätze für Erwachsene. Warum gibt es keine Spielplätze für Erwachsene? Hm, warum nicht? Ja, durfte ich ja nicht recherchieren. Es gibt ja nur dann ... Also ich hab dann recherchiert trotzdem, und es gibt ja nur so Abenteuerspielplätze oder so, aber keine ... Also dann geht's halt richtig ums Sportliche, ne, aber keine ... Einfach nuritparks? Ja, aber es ist ja auch was anderes, das muss ja richtig Eintritt zahlen, das ist ja nicht so schön. Atmo. Das ist ganz schön, es fängt gerade sehr stark an zu regnen, wir hören das gerade, ich finde das ganz angenehm. Bist du so ein Regenmensch, kannst du da, ja? Ja, ich finde das ganz schön, so schön in der Park. Bei uns zu Gast, nein, Florentin hat nicht einfach nur nur neuerdings seine Frauenstimme perfektioniert, wir haben eine junge Dame zu Gast, namens Lena Kupke. Hallo. Du bist Schauspielerin, Komödien, Putzfrau. Du hast einen Pizzaladen, du hast einen Kartoffeladen. Du machst dir die Buchhaltung nebenbei. Wir wollen uns erstmal bedanken für deine Dienste bis dato und dich ganz herzlich in das Podcast begrüssen. Ich freue mich, dass ich hier bin. Vielen Dank. Eines der besten Fingermodels Deutschlands. Dankeschön. Kann man so sagen. Du hast echt schöne Finger, kann man wirklich mal sagen. Ja, das kann man so sagen. Es wurde auch schon mehrfach fotografiert und die haben auch versucht, mich als Fingermodel unterzubringen. Leider nicht so erfolgreich. Weil du immer dein Gesicht in die Kamera auch noch gehalten hast. Das ist richtig, ja. Das ist richtig. Aber es ist bestimmt ein hartes Business als Fingermodel. Ich könnte mir da so eine Sitcom vorstellen, wo jemand unbedingt Fingermodel werden will und alles nur den ganzen Tag auf seinen Finger fokussiert ist. Aber die Szene ist halt hart. Ich möchte einen ganz kurzen historischen Ausflug machen. Wie ist die Mafia entstanden? Wie ist die Mafia entstanden? Nein, und zwar das Problem war, damals in Sizilien haben sehr viele Menschen vom Zitronenanbau gelebt. Sie haben Zitronenbäume gepflanzt und die Zitronen geerntet und die verkauft. Das Problem an einem Zitronenbusiness ist, dass ein potenzieller Konkurrent, ein Neider, könnte einfach mit einer Axt in deinen Garten kommen und innerhalb von einer halben Stunde deinen gesamten Obstgarten zerlegen und alle deine Zitronenbäume kaputt hacken und das war es dann erst mal. Es dauert dann erst mal wieder zwölf Jahre, bis die ganzen Zitronenbäume nachgewachsen sind, das heißt, du bist einfach ruiniert, du hast einfach alles, deine gesamte Existenz ist hinfort, futsch, ja, dahin, dahin. Futschi, dato. Und da haben sich die Bauern dann gedacht, okay, wir brauchen irgendwelche Leute, die meinen Obstgarten beschützen, also holen wir uns Mafiosi und so ist die Mafia langsam bestanden. Sie hatten komischerweise erst den Namen, bevor es dann später irgendeine Bedeutung bekommen hat. Ja, das war ein bisschen seltsam in diesem Zeitartikel. Wir brauchen Mafiosi, Onkel Mafiosi, könnt ihr vielleicht aufpassen. Genau, und so haben sie sich dann, und auch dann irgendwann haben dann die ganzen Beschützer der Gärten sich untereinander bekriegt und dann haben die dann irgendwann Schutzgeld bezahlt. Also so eine Schrebergartenaktion. Im Grunde ist es aus einer sehr spiessigen Intention entstanden. wenn die dann den Gedanken entwickeln, dass sie auch selber ja die Limetten einfach klauen können. Ja. Und dann haben die angefangen, dass die Kriminalität quasi auswirkt. Ja genau, die haben dann sozusagen mit ihrem Schutz den Bauern erpresst. Wie mit der Schippe im Sandkasten eigentlich. Äh, erläutere. Erläutere. Naja, wer hat die Schippe weggenommen? Und dann baut sich so eine Front auf, die versucht, die Schippe wieder zurückzugewinnen und so dieses Kindergartenprinzip. Nein? Geh nochmal näher drauf ein oder erzähl es nochmal. Wer ist genau die Schippe jetzt in diesen beiden? Wer von uns beiden ist die Schippe, was willst du gerade sagen? Ich hatte Schwierigkeiten mit den ganzen Informationen von dir, weil es waren so viele Informationen mit Zitronen und Limon und ich hatte die ganze Zeit in meinem Kopf so einen wunderschönen italienischen Garten mit Zitronenbäumen. Du hattest einen Geruch in der Nase, gibst du? Was? Du hattest einen Geruch in der Nase. Du hast in den Urlaub gedacht. Ich hatte, ja, das stimmt, das ist wohl wahr. Ich habe mich schon gesehen in Sizilien. War Sizilien überhaupt? Sagt man auch auf Sizilien. Welche Gerüche magst du gerne? Lavendel? Was sind deine Top-17-Gerüche? Okay, okay, 17? Ja, Top-17! Okay, Lavendel, Santo Pallo-Räucherstäbchenchen, Tempel-Duft aus Bali. Warum liest du von der Liste ab, was ist das? Ich hab doch gar keine Liste! Du hast ja einfach so einen Zettel rausgeholt, auf deinem Arm geschrieben. Das ist imaginär, weisst du, ich bringe schon mal, so jetzt unterbrechen, also Vanille, Zimt, Kakao, Kaffee, obwohl ich Kaffee nicht mag, was komisch ist, ich weiss, Salz, Regen, Regen, der Duft von Schlamm und Erde, Gras, was wächst und grün ist. Warum haben wir so wenig Grün auf der Welt, Blätter, Sonnenstrahlen, Salz, wie es nach dem Meer auf meiner Haut trocknet, Speichel von allen Leuten. Das waren 17. Ja, danke schön, danke. danke schön! Aber es ist dir aufgefallen, ich habe dich vor ein paar Tagen gesehen, da waren wir bei Baris für Rares, nein, Kunst gegen Baris, so, und dann war da auch eine Poetry-Slammerin, die hat die Bühne betreten und ich wusste, dass sie eine Poetry-Slammerin ist, obwohl sie noch drei Worte gesagt hat, weil sie fing direkt an zu sagen, ja, ich habe heute leider keine Texte mitgebracht und ich bin jetzt hier auf der Bühne und ich habe schon gelacht und sie hat sich einfach nur vorgestellt. Und ich dachte mir direkt, halt einfach deine Fresse. Ich werde hier nur auf der Bühne stehen, Dinge verstehen, auch mal andere Wege gehen, sich selbst in dem Spiegel sehen. Was ist wahr, bin ich wahr, ist das die Realität, ja, es ist die fucking Realität. Das ist einfach nur Nonsens, wenn man das aufschreiben würde, das ist nur Schwachsinn. Ja, das finde ich aber schön, weil man kann ja jeden beschissenen Text nehmen und den so vorlesen und keiner merkt. Das finde ich das Schöne. Man kann auch immer so reden und dann weiss man nicht, man erwartet aber immer Reime. Und dann hat sie angefangen. Nee, du musst auch dieses angestrengte Gesicht dabei machen, also wenn du ganz angestrengt überlegst, was jetzt als nächstes kommt. Dieses Suchende immer, dieses Reden, die Erde beben, beleben, sich selbst erheben und dann auf andere weisen gehen. Ihr habt das schon drauf. Du solltest einen Song daraus machen. Du machst kein Päusel lernen. Was machst du denn stattdessen? Was mache ich denn stattdessen? Comedy. Ja, ein bisschen Stand-Up und schreiben und spielen. Was spielst du denn so? Brummi-Cup? Was? Brummi-Cup? Nee, Mau, Mau Mau. Ich kann mir doch keine Regeln merken, ich bin ganz Mau Mau. Ich finde Mau Mau geil, dass du theoretisch ... Was siehst du denn da eigentlich? Ich hab meine Studenten-Futter mitgebracht, mit Cranberries. Ach so, ich hab mich grad gewundert. Und Mau Mau, du weisst immer, welche Karte du legen musst, weil normalerweise wird am Ende noch, wenn jemand Mau gemacht hat, wird am Ende die Punkte gezählt.
Wenn du die Punkte gezählt!
Du musst immer die höchste Karte legen, die du legen kannst.
Weil dann, wenn du die höchste Karte gelegt hast, du weniger Punkte hast.
Und dann kannst du am Ende, also eigentlich hast du immer nur eine Karte, die du legen musst.
Das ist halt das Mau-Mau-Mau-Prinzip.
Also mich ein bisschen stürmer, Mau-Mau, weil es ein bisschen einfällig ist.
Poker.
Poker, interessant. Gib mal uns deinen Pok dein Pokerface. Warte. Wein. So traurig ist. Sie schüttelt sich gerade ihre Haare ins Gesicht. Ich weiss nicht, ob das zählt. Nein, nein, ich bereite mich vor. Wow. Das ist nicht schlecht. Es war für eine Millisekunde gehalten. Und jetzt, wenn du blufst, kannst du dich mit meinem Bluffgesicht machen? Ja, machst du das so auffällig? Ja. Okay, mein Bluffgesicht ist auf jeden Fall ... Sehr streng. Ich versuche, wenn ich bliffe, immer so zu tun, als hätte ich die Regeln nicht verstanden. So ein bisschen so ... Zeit gewinnen oder so. Ja, ja. Wenn man eins von jeder Farbe hat, ist schon gut, oder? Also, oder? Dann bin ich jetzt schon richtig. Okay, dann all in. Einfach so. Das ist immer die beste Art. Ich habe, wenn ich Poker spiele, immer im Kopf, wenn Leute die Regeln nicht verstehen, dann bin ich immer vorsichtig, weil die könnten halt aus Versehen gewinnen. Und das ist unberechenbar. Und hollaberweise sind bei Poker Leute immer berechenbar, aber nicht, wenn die Leute die Regeln nicht verstehen. Ja, das bin ich. Du bist unberechenbar. Das bin ich, ich bin unberechenbar, ja. Ich verstehe auch keine Regeln, weil ich es mir nicht merke, weil es mir zu viele Regeln sind.
Ich glaube, Poker ist eines der wenigen Spiele, wo ein absoluter Anfänger relativ einfachen Profi schlagen kann, weil man so viel auf Intuition und Logik basiert, dass der Anfänger durch sein Chaos und durch seine reine Energie sich selbst das Spiel leben, das Leben spiel, das Spiel leben, sich selbst erleben, die Erde bebt. Aber sie kam auf die Bühne, hat dann so gesprochen, dann hat sie aber gesagt, ich wollte heute eigentlich Texte vorlesen, habe ich aber nicht mitgebracht. Doch, sie hat sich anders entschieden, weil der Abend ja so politisch schon gestartet ist, möchte sie jetzt was anderes. Was anderes erleben. Das ist das Schlimmste der Welt. Und dann hat sie überlegt, sie teilt das Publikum in Drums und Beat ein. Was sehr gut bei mir geklappt hat. Ja, ich war mehr damit beschäftigt, darauf zu achten, den Takt zu halten, als ihr zuzuhören. Ich glaube, sie hat die krasseste Performance der Welt abgeliefert. Sie hat 15 Minuten lang gefreestylt, aber ich habe einfach nicht zuhören können. Das hätte der Weltrekord im Freestyle sein können, keine Ahnung. Ich habe die ganze Zeit da versucht, ihm den Takt zu halten. Aber du hast das durchgezogen, 15 Minuten? Durchgezogen, ja. Boah, ich habe dann irgendwann nur noch mit dem Bein gemacht, dann irgendwann ist dann mein Bein eingeschlappt und dann hab ich nur noch mit den Händen so, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Aber das finde ich echt lustig, dass ich einfach das outgesourced habe aufs Publikum. Ich war einfach mega beschäftigt damit. Ich hatte echt Montag, Dienstag einen absoluten Höllentrip in Mainz, aber rückblickend, es war zumindest kein Poetry-Slam dabei. Das ist passiert. Das ist, glaube ich, schon ganz gut. Das hast du erlebt. Erzähl uns alles. Der Veranstaltung, ich glaube, aus politischen Gründen kann ich da nichts dazu eingehen.
Aber ihr habt ja eine tolle Show gemacht und du machst Comedy, du machst ein bisschen Spaß, ein paar Gag. Das ist schon ganz gut. Wir waren auf so einer ZDF-Veranstaltung. Ich glaube, aus politischen Gründen kann ich da nichts dazu eingehen.
Aber ihr habt ja eine tolle Show gemacht und du machst Comedy, du machst ein bisschen Spaß, ein paar Gags, irgendwie denkst du bist lustig auf der Bühne oder was. Mensch mal, ha ha ha und hi hi hi. Ja, ich habe im Februar erst damit angefangen, das möchte ich ganz offen hier sagen. Ich habe aber vorher auch lustiges Theater gemacht, auch selber geschrieben und ist das jetzt ein Bewerbungsgespräch eigentlich? Ja. Okay. Okay, ähm ...
Was, in 2009 haben sie eine Lücke in Ihrem Lebenslauf. Was genau war da los? Da war ein privates, grosse Katastrophe. Möchtest du da drauf eingehen? Da ist meine Space-Taste hängen geblieben. Nee, es war mein Hamster. Ihr Hamster? Verstehe ich das nicht? Sie haben ein Jahr gefehlt. Ja, den haben Sie ja mal im Lebenslauf. Warum, was ist das für eine Beziehung?
Ja, der hatte eine wichtige Rolle für mich und ich habe den bekommen, als ich acht war, ist er mit 13, ist er gestorben, aber wir haben ihn noch mal ausgestopft, sodass ich immer das Gefühl hatte, er lebt noch. Also mein Vater ist Ingenieur, der hat Batterien reingesetzt, einfach damit ich als Kind das Gefühl hatte, er lebt noch. Oh mein Gott. Und 2009, Sie sprachen es gerade an, man wird schlauer, man lernt mit den Jahren, so auch ich, und dann habe ich einfach festgestellt, das ist ein Betrug. Mausi lebt nicht mehr, Mausi ist ein Roboter. Das tut mir leid. Und haben Sie ein Jahr damit zu kämpfen gehabt? Das ist schon sehr lang. Das war natürlich für mich ein tiefer Einschnitt und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, das begleitet mich bis heute.
Also ein hamsterter Mausi.
Aber das ist jetzt ein Problem, weil wir bei Hamster und Co sind natürlich...
Sie haben uns eigentlich gesagt, dass wir Co und Hamster heissen eigentlich.
Die Memo hast du bekommen.
Aber es finde ich eigentlich schön, dass das wieder aus meinem Lebenslauf so aufgegriffen wird und vielleicht ist jetzt der Zeitpunkt, für mich Frieden zu schliessen und auch nochmal neue Erlebnisse mit Hamstern zu machen. Wir machen jetzt ein bisschen Sorgen, dass Sie andauernd durch den Namen daran erinnert werden, an Ihren grossen Verlust von damals. Ich bin medikamentös soweit gut eingestellt, da sollte eigentlich nichts passieren. Okay, dann möchte ich jetzt mal Ihre Reflexe testen. Ja, ich weiss nicht genau, wie man jetzt reagiert, aber sie haben relativ normal reagiert. Musst du mir nicht gegen das Knie hauen? Ja, einen Moment. Warte, aber das musst du runter bauen. Das ist nicht ihr Knie. Jetzt, das ist ihr Knie. Oh Mann, ich bin aufgeregt jetzt. Oh, das waren 17 Sekunden Verzögerung, ich weiss nicht, ob das so gut ist. Ja, ich würde sagen, sie sind eingestellt. Aber, ne, wer zuletzt lacht, lacht am besten. Das ist gut, dafür kriegen Sie gleich noch einen Job umdrauf. Dankeschön! Und weisst du was, was soll der Geiz, Sie kriegen noch einen dritten Job umdrauf! Was soll der Geiz, wir hauen heute alles raus. Super, vielen Dank. Hattest du viele Nebenjobs in deinem Leben? Ja, du bist ja eine Künstlennatur, du kommst hier rein, sagst sofort, ich habe früher am Theater gearbeitet, das war der erste Satz, den du gesagt hast.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt, ich habe gesagt, das sieht ja aus wie ein Theater und da hast du gesagt, du kommst ja auch aus dem Theater, woher auch immer du das weißt. Und du hast auch sehr selbstbewusst Ja gesagt. Noch bevor ich Hallo sagen konnte, sagst du, ja, ich habe ja früher am Theater gearbeitet, hast seinen Schädel in der Hand gehabt und Hamlet zitiert. Also cooler Eindruck, erstmal cooler Essay, aber ich denke, du hast wahrscheinlich viel in deinem Leben, irgendwie viel deinen Träumen nachgejagt. Ich habe viel erlebt. Du hast viel gejagt, Dinge gewagt, auch mal andere Dinge bestiegen, das Theater gespielt und hast natürlich auch nebenbei ein bisschen Geld verdient, nehme ich mal an.
Was hattest du für so Nebenjobs?
Was war dein höchster Kontostand jemals?
Oh, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ja, aber auch ein bisschen weird.
Das ist mega privat auch, ne?
Ja, mega privat, aber du kannst auch lügen, das ist komplett egal hier.
Aber wir sehen halt, dass du lügst.
2000.
2000. Was? Panikas? Euro. Euro? Ja! Warte mal, ich geb dir Mann zwar nie, das kann doch nicht sein. Du musst aber auch nicht kommen, ey. Das arme Mädchen bekommen. Studentenfutter möchtest du das haben, das sind einfach Nüsse, aber er kommt für die Woche mit über die Runden. Du brauchst ein bisschen. Aber das heisst, du hast immer auf dem dünnen Taler gelebt. Ja, das ist meine Jacke, die ist immer noch nass. Das fühlt sich ganz gut an eigentlich. Jetzt hör auf daran zu riechen, so intensiv. Entschuldige, könnt ihr mich eine Sekunde alleine lassen, bitte? Ich brauche nicht lange. Aber was hattest du für so Nebenjobs so nebenbei? Die Geld gebracht haben? Alles, wirklich alles. Gut, dann kommen wir zur nächsten Frage. Wenn du so antwortest, dann lassen wir das. Wenn du wenn du so antwortest, interessiert mich eher die Jobs, die kein Geld gebracht haben. Ich bin schon rot jetzt. Wenn du fragst, die, die Geld gebracht haben ... Und das macht mich rot, ne? Und die, die Geld gebracht haben, machen mich nicht ... äh, die kein Geld ... Was waren das für welche? Moment, okay, ich muss ... also, wo ich am meisten ... das war die Frage, wo ich am meisten Geld verdient habe, oder? Das war seine Frage. Ich versuche ein paar saftige Anekdoten aus dir rauszukriegen. Achso, ja, ich meine ... okay, das ist ja so, du weisst ja nicht, wie viel ich erlebt habe, deswegen weiss ich überhaupt nicht, in welchem Feld ich anfangen soll. Ich war einmal sowas wie eine Puffmutter. Yeah! Okay, was heißt, bitte lass uns über den Begriff sowas wie ne reden. Was hat dich und eine Puffmutter noch unterschieden? Dass es im Kostüm eines Kunstprojektes kam. Aha, gut, dann war ich auch schon mal ein Roboter. Das kannst du nicht sagen. Die hatten wirklich Sex und ich habe das koordiniert. Ich war schon mal D'Artagnan. Und ich habe die Kunden angeworben. Okay, erklär mir dieses Kunstprojekt noch mal. Okay, also es war so, es war ein Künstler aus der Schweiz und sein Projekt bestand darin, dass er sich als Callboy verkauft hat. Und er hatte so ein Zelt, das war so ein pinkes Zelt, ich darf jetzt keine Namen nennen, und mein Job war es, Leute anzuwerben und zu sagen, hey, das ist jetzt hier der Künstler XY, der ist da im Zelt, du kannst einfach da reingehen, du kannst dir wünschen, was immer du willst, auch sexuelle Dienste, das kostet so und so viel oder ihr besprecht die Preise untereinander und ich koordiniere die Termine. Hatte zur Folge, dass ein älterer Herr reinkam und mich fragte, ja macht der auch so römisch, so antik, so kämpfen und danach dann den Geschlechtsakt? Und ich sagte, ja, natürlich, herein, herein, spaziert in die Manege. Und dann bin ich davor stehen geblieben und musste immer auf die Zeit gucken, weil jeder Kunde hatte nur so zehn Minuten. Aber das ist schon so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines und ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines
und ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines
und ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, und ich habe, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, so ein kleines, Dienste anzubieten, habe ich aber nicht gemacht.
Aber was war das denn für ein Kunstprojekt? Also die Idee war, dass es alles in der Öffentlichkeit stattfindet?
Dass es in der Öffentlichkeit stattfindet und praktisch auch Enttabuisierung, weil jeder nutzt ja Prostitution und ist ja ältestes Gewerbe der Welt und bla bla bla bla bla. Und wurde es dann auch irgendwie gefilmt oder so, oder war das wirklich nur so ein Happening? Das war nur ein Happening, es gab auch einen Teil, der gefilmt wurde, aber das war natürlich nicht, wenn Leute den privat gebucht haben, wie das da der Fall war. Und der hat auch wirklich dann Geld angenommen dafür? Ja, der hat das nur für Geld gemacht, ja. Wie ist das denn steuerlich, wenn du jetzt einfach sagst, das ist ein Gewerbe, aber ich meine, du kannst nicht einfach sagen, ich mache hier ein Gewerbe auf und das ist Kunst, weil es ist auf Marktplatz, aber an sich ist es ja ein Gewerbe, wenn du damit Geld verdienst. Wenn du ein Bordell hast, könntest du dann auch einfach sagen, das ist ein Kunstprojekt. Das ist ein riesiges Kunstprojekt, kann das eigentlich immer so. Sorry, das ist ein Riesen, wir haben ja auch ein paar Bilder aufgehangen von Ikea. Du brauchst ja schon Referenzen und die hatte der ja. Der hat dann auf irgendwelche Theoretiker verwiesen, die sich damit …
Ja, oder irgendwelche Kulturoretiker verwiesen, die sich damit...
Ja, oder irgendwelche Kulturmagazine haben über den geschrieben, was auch immer.
Der ist auch rumgetourt.
Und es war eigentlich ganz geil, der hatte auch ein Theaterstück über sein Leben.
Und irgendwie hat er seinen Eltern immer erzählt, er hat so viel Geld, weil er ein Stipendium hat.
Und die Eltern haben das halt immer geglaubt.
Und er war dann auch in New York und hat zu New York gelebt und war mega reich und die Eltern immer so stolz. Boah, der Junge, ne, der studiert und hat ein Stipendium, so toll und ja. Fick sich durch die Welt, muss man mal ganz richtig sagen. Und die Mutter ist auch noch so richtig, die Mutter ist noch Psychologin und so alle, alle Klischees bedient. Das heißt, sie weiss, dass er lügt, aber sie sagt dem Mann wahrscheinlich nicht, weil sie es selber nicht glauben will. Da war ich auf jeden Fall dabei. Das ist abgefahren. Das war wirklich abgefahren, da habe ich mich auch kurz gefragt, was …
Bin ich auf dem richtigen Weg?
Bin ich auf dem richtigen Weg? Auf welchem Weg bin ich überhaupt?
War das in der Schweiz oder ein Schweizer Künstler in Deutschland?
Ja, das war schon viel zu über.
Was machst du in der Schweiz irgendwie?
Nein, nein, der war in Deutschland. Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht richtig zugehört.
Der war in Deutschland?
Der war in Deutschland, der war in Deutschland, wir waren beide in Deutschland.
Alle waren in Deutschland. Tolles Land, oder? Deutschland ist so ein tolles Land. Was gefällt dir am besten am Deutschland? Der Regel ist eine Art der Klinischen und der Klinischen und der Klinischen und der Klinischen und der Kächste Frage, wie würdest du gerne mal Geld verdienen, wo willst du hin, was ist dein Ziel, was ist the big picture? The big picture ist mit der Kunst. Also mit am liebsten mit …
Was ist für dich Kunst?
Oh Mann, ich hasse diese Frage. Ich hasse, hasse, hasse diese Frage, wirklich.
Kunst ist das, was man selber produziert. Ist auch Kacke.
Also mein Nutella-Toast heute Morgen war Kunst.
Hey, mach sie mal jetzt nicht lustig.
Ne, ich habe hier selber drüber gelesen.
Das für sie Kunst ist, das für sie Kunst, okay?
Man kann auch mal schön in die Ecke kacken, dann ist das auch Kunst, so gibt es ja auch. Damit, ich würde gerne mit meinen Geschichten, die in meinem Kopf sind und dass ich die umsetzen kann, ich würde gerne Drehbücher schreiben, selber spielen und damit mich komplett finanzieren, was teilweise auch geklappt hat und das ja immer so von Projekt zu Projekt. Geklappt bis 2000 Euro auf dem Konto. Ich meine, es hat geklappt. Vielen Dank! Sehr lange Geld, ich würde noch mal aufweisen. Ich habe immer so ein bisschen Geld angespart, aus dem Grund, die haben wir schon ein paar Mal erzählt, die Geschichte, dass wir beide Angst haben, dass irgendwann das Finanzamt kommt und sagt, du hast, weil du dumm bist, Steuerinterziehungsbetrieben seit 50 Jahren, du lebst erst seit 20 Jahren, aber du hast in Höhe von 50 Jahren. Du bist erst 20 Jahre alt? Ich bin 21 Jahre alt. Aber trotzdem, dass man halt irgendwann das Finanzamt kommt und sagt, no way. Ganz kurz, wie alt bist du? 25. What? Ist das jetzt euer Ernst? Ja. Nein, werben wir lo. Ich bin neunzehn. Ich bin siebzehn. Ich möchte an dieser Stelle diese Sendung verlassen. Hey! Du hast es nicht immer eine Sendung genannt, das ist schon mal ein Lob. Ich habe mich gerade ein bisschen stolz gefühlt, dass sie sagt Sendung verlassen. Und nicht einfach zwei Vollidioten mit Mikrofon. Blödel-Podcast wurden wir neulich genannt. Ja, wir wurden Blödel-Podcast genannt. Oh, wer hat das denn gesagt? Ganz komisch. Wer denn, so ein Kritiker? Na, auf Twitter, wir können jetzt auch einfach Fanshaming betreiben. Ja, und wie alt war der Blödel? Aber es ist einfach so gut, wenn jemand so ein Lob, ich glaube, es war generell schon Lob, aber dann irgendwie mit dem Wort. Ja, das kenne ich. Also das ist echt mein Lieblingsblödel-Podcast. Aber ich finde das ganz schön. Eigentlich, hm. Das ist so Mobbing durch Loben irgendwie. Ja, ja, ja, so positiver Rassismus, ne? Auf jeden Fall. Das ist ganz schlimm, aber auch ganz nett. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das so finden soll. Genau, von Daniel Döge. Liebe Grüße an Dögi Dögi. What up, Daniel? Dögi! Der schreibt, hab tatsächlich wegen einem Blödel-Podcast etwas Podcast-Ufo eine neue Bettdecke bestellt. Wehe, da steht nicht NASA drauf. Wir haben in der letzten Folge über Bettdecken. Man kann Bettdecken von uns bestellen. Mit euch drauf als Foto? Nee, nämlich nicht mit uns drauf, sondern nur mit das Podcast-Ufo drauf. Keep it das Podcast-Ufo. Bist du ein Motiv-Bettdecken-Schläfer? Nee, überhaupt nicht. Nee? Ganz weiss oder eher schlichte Muster, schlichte Formen? Eher schlichte, ja, eher schlichte Farben. Farben auch? Girly, girly? Überhaupt gar nicht. Pinky? Ne, gar nicht. Welche Farben? Ja, so Erdtöne, Schlammtöne. Ah, Pastell. Damit, ne, man auch nicht alle Flecken immer direkt sieht. Oh! Genau, so das, was halt gerade, wie gesagt, was bei Aldi so im Angebot ist. Das findet man bei mir im Ikea-Bett. Wie machst du es, wenn es so warm ist? Wie ich es mache, wenn es so warm ist? Ja, dass du nachts nicht schwitzt. Ah, ich schwitze grundsätzlich immer sehr viel, also das lässt sich nicht vermeiden, aber ich habe jetzt einen Trick. Oh, jetzt gerade, du hast das dritte Shirt schon an jetzt. Ja, du hast vier Jacken an, ich will auch sagen. Mann, ich schwitze es halt durch, aber ich habe mir ja Ersatz-Shirts mitgebracht, ich bin halt so ein Schwitzi. Da nehme ich einfach die Bettdecke aus dem Bettlaken raus und decke mich nur mit dem Bettlaken zu. What? Krasser Scheiss. Nicht so schlecht. Das ist gut. Das ist wirklich nicht so gut. Aber das ist dann zu dünn einfach für mich. Ich muss was in der Hand haben. Warum? Wenn's doch, aber das kannst du ja auch in die Hand nehmen. Ich weiss auch nicht, warum ich nicht schlafen kann, wenn ich keine Bettdecke habe, weil eigentlich von der Temperatur her ist es ja eigentlich, wenn es einem zu warm ist, aber man braucht irgendwie was. Was dich damit beschützt und geborgen fühlst vielleicht? Ja, irgendwie schon, ich glaube, das ist ein urmenschlicher Instinkt, ich finde es auch mega scheisse, dass du jetzt auf so eine lächerliche Ebene rüber ziehst. Nein, ich meine es auch nicht. Das ist einfach ein urmenschlicher Instinkt, dass man sich einfach nach Geborgenheit und einer gewissen Nähe sehnt, das ist auch ganz normal, so, und ich weiß nicht, warum ich jetzt hier von zwei Leuten ausgelacht werde und bespuckt werde, keine Ahnung, man sehnt sich halt nach Sicherheit und Ge und Geborgenheit. Es wurde endlich herausgefunden, warum man, wenn man die erste Nacht woanders schläft, nicht gut schlafen kann. Erzähl. Es ist nämlich so, dass eine Gehirnhälfte, meistens die linke, spielt gar keine Rolle, die sind im weiteren Verlauf, aber diese Gehirnhälfte schaltet sich einfach, bleibt einfach an, weil die Angst hat, also wenn man woanders schläft, zum Beispiel damals in einer anderen Höhle geschlafen hat, wenn man in der Steinzeit war, hat man halt Angst, man kennt die Umgebung noch nicht, ist es vielleicht nicht sicher und dann ist ein Gehirnhälfte auf Alarmbereitschaft und dann schläfst du halt nie wirklich tief, weil immer die andere Hälfte schläft. Genau, die andere Hälfte ist völlig weg. Die total emotionale Seite ist noch wach. Ich war im Urlaub und ich hatte eine Nacht grosse Angst vor Einbrechern und dann habe ich mich so verbarrikadiert, weil ich dachte, wenn jetzt ein Einbrecher kommt, dann werde ich durch die Geräusche wach.
Ja.
Und dann lag ich aber im Bett und dachte, boah, ich bin so angespannt, dass ich nicht schlafen kann, mache ich mir Oropax rein und dann dachte ich, aber ist ja vielleicht irgendwie doof, weil dann höre ich ja nichts mehr. Also schalte ich jetzt meine Sinne aus oder nicht? Aber was ich mich mal frage, warum willst du denn überhaupt aufwachen, wenn ein Einbrecher kommt? Das Beste, was doch passieren wäre, würde, ist, du wachst morgens auf und merkst, oh fuck, ich wurde ausgeräubt. Ja gut, ich meinte auch mit Einbrecher, nicht Einbrecher, sondern eher schon so ein Vergewaltiger.
Aber auch da ist doch besser, wenn du morgens aufwachst und denkst, warum bin ich aber schwanger.
Ich fühle mich nicht ganz so gut, aber was war irgendwas?
Ich bin so ein bisschen wundgescheuert, aber ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich hatte einen ganz seltsamen Traum eigentlich.
Ja, fand ich ganz interessant.
Vor allem, wenn eine Gehirnhälfte ist ja die sehr analytische und die andere Gehirnhälfte ist die sehr emotionale Gehirnhälfte. Und ich finde die Vorstellung lustig, wenn eine Gehirnhälfte sich ausschaltet und die ganze Zeit also weinerlich bist und total emotional, weil du halt irgendwo anders denkst und wie vermisst. Dann kommt jemand rein, du schreist ihn sofort an, du bist total megawütend. Und du hast gar kein Komplett alles Rationale hast du vergessen, weil die Gehirnhälfte einfach schläft. Aber ich meine zum Beispiel, im Gehirn gibt es ja das Sprachzentrum. Und Sprache kann ja sowohl emotional als auch logisch sein. Du hast ja Grammatik und so, hast aber dann mit Sprache, also Poetry Slam weckt ja auch gewisse Gefühle über eine Sprache. Hass vor allem. Vor allem Hass ist ja emotional, aber Sprache ist auf der einen Seite auch sehr analytisch und logisch und grammatikalisch aufgebaut. Also das kann ja gar nicht sagen, so was ist jetzt jetzt die Trainerin. Ja, aber es gibt ja, dann ist die vielleicht in beiden Bereichen, so in der Mitte. Ja, vielleicht ist es einfach in der Mitte. Ich finde, das, was du gerade gesagt hast, hat mich gerade echt berührt auf eine Art. Vielen Dank, Florian. Sowohl logisch als auch auf einer emotionalen Ede hat mir das echt was gegeben. Danke, das bedeutet mir super viel, danke. Total wohl habe ich mich gerade gefühlt innerlich, danke. Ist du gerne Pilze? Ähm, Champignons, ja. Ja, Pifferlinge? Nein, nein, nein, nein. So ein bisschen die Köpfe abnaschen? Nein, da bin ich gar nicht so eine süße Naschmaus, wie du vielleicht meinst. Warte, hör auf! Nein, du, nein, du! Ne, da habe ich echt so einen Kindergeschmack. Aber Pilze, glaube ich, meinte er im Sinne von Drogen. Ne, ich meinte doch schon wirklich normalerweise. Ich hab da extra nicht drauf reagiert, weil ich dachte ... Nein, natürlich nicht, natürlich gar nicht. Wir haben immer überlegt, Pilze zu nehmen. Ja, und dann … Ja, lass uns nach Amsterdam fahren und das machen, so diese Magic-Mastrooms. Aber ist Amsterdam Pilzort? Ja. Und dann so an den Deich setzen und dann … Nicht an den Deich in Amsterdam, da setze ich einen Kanal und frische Pommes und guckst dir die Holländer an. Na, weil wir sind gerade an einem neuen Projekt dran und suchen einen Namen und wir stecken so ein bisschen in ein Kreativloch. Und da dachten wir uns, dass wir uns einfach irgendwie alle Drogen der Welt einmal nehmen, so einfach hier so... So eine bunte Tüte. ...für Heroin für zwei Mark. Heroin. Und dann einfach uns mal zurückziehen und einfach einen coolen Namen erfinden. Ja, das ist ja ein bombastischer Plan, ihr beiden hier. Ja, ungefähr so wie Silicon Valley Staffel eins. Wow, wir klauen noch Serien, noch amerikanischen Serien mittlerweile schon. Das ist ein toller Podcast. Wir hassen uns, ey. Vielleicht kommt man da einfach auch bessere Ideen und dann kann man so bewusst erweitern, einfach mal, da hat man die Idee des Namens. Stefan zum Beispiel. Wow. Oder Lena. Lena, kennst du Lena, mein Landhoff? Nein. Warum, woher soll ich die kennen? Weil ich Lena heiße. Wow. Oder Lena, Lena, kennst du Lena bei Landroth? Nein. Warum, woher soll ich die kennen? Weil du so heisst, wie sie es ist. Weil ich Lena heisse. Stimmt, warte mal. Kann ich dich Leni, kann ich dich Hello Leni nennen für den Rest des Podcasts? Auf gar keinen Fall, wobei Leni ist tatsächlich, Leute, die mich mögen, nennen mich Leni. Ich verstehe mal nicht, warum man Spitznamen macht, die die gleiche Silbenanzahl haben wie der Originalname. Das ist so … Ja, wegen dem I, das ist ja dieser i, weisst du so. Aber die Chance, dass du genauso heisst wie Lena Meilandroth, also diese vier Buchstaben, sind sehr gering, weil du hast 26 Buchstaben hoch vier, hoch vier. Im Quadrat die Wurzel aus. Schätz mal, was 26 hoch vier sind. 145.000. 145.000. Nein, sag nochmal bitte. Ne, ich schätze mal, was 26 hoch 4. 26 hoch 4? Ich schätze, ja, acht Millionen. 26 hoch 4. Was habe ich als erstes gesagt? 456.000. So, was habe ich als erstes gesagt? Es war fast, komm, es war fast. Ja, war nicht schlecht. War gut. Sehr gut. Vielen Dank, danke. Echt klug. Ja, ich we, danke schön. Alles okay? Entschuldigung. Alles okay? Man darf auch, glaube ich, nicht so trockenes Zeug essen, wenn man die ganze Zeit spricht. Nee, das bleibt dir dann so stecken. Was sind deine Tricks, um eine sanfte Stimme mit auf die Bühne zu nehmen? Habe ich jetzt heute nicht gemacht. Wasser. Sprech-Sprachübungen, so ein paar Übungen. Okay, hau mal ein paar raus. Oh ja, oh ja, oh ja, oh ja, oh ja, oh ja, und ganz gutes und dann gibt's noch so eine Atemkacke und so springen und sich hier so draufhauen und dann passiert locker und das war nicht mehr.
Das kann ich nicht haben, das ist ganz schlecht. Nein, das war einfach.
Warum denn nicht?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist der Stimmst, ja, auf den Kirchhoff ist schlimm.
Lass mich in den Russ. Ich finde das auch, wenn manchmal Sänger oder so für ganz spezielle Sachen dann auch so singen und, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho so ein kurzer, damit auch klar ist, es ist einfach nur Höflichkeit.
Zum Beispiel fände ich es gut, wenn man irgendwie so Vorführungen Applaus gibt, aber man gibt nicht fortwährenden Applaus, sondern man schlägt nur einmal in die Hand und alle gleichzeitig so, hier ist Stefan Tietze, wamm und dann tritt er einfach auf und das einfach dann zur Geltung genommen. Ich würde gerne mal eine Comedy-Show sehen, wo Leute nicht lachen, aber applaudieren.
Was muss ein Comedian sagen, was muss ich, wenn ich mal wieder im Boeing bin, hier in Köln, fünf Minuten mache, was muss ich sagen, damit alle, weiß ich nicht, damit alle klatschen, aber niemand lacht, was für eine wehre Situation ist das. Doch ich weiss, ich glaube ich weiss, du musst sowas Pseudo-Intellektuelles sagen. Ja, vielleicht. Worauf man, weisst du nicht so ein alberner, hahaha, sondern … Und hier ist Lena Krupke! Und jetzt sag mal irgendwas, was diesen Effekt hervorheben würde. Ich schreibe, um zu verstehen, ohne zu verstehen, was ich schreibe. Ja gut, das war jetzt leider nicht lustig, ne, besser wäre es … Ja, soll ja auch nicht lustig sein, damit er nicht l Ja, wenn es in einem Stand-Up, in einer Comedy-Routine wäre, und dann niemand lacht, aber trotzdem klappt. Aber dann darf es ja nicht lustig sein, weil dann würden ja die Leute lachen. Du hast eine ganz verrückte Frisur, du hast irgendwie zwei verschiedene Haarlängen in deiner Frisur. Siehst du das hier? Guck mal, der vordere Teil ist so mittellang, bis zum Hals, und dann der Rest ist... Klassischer Stufenschnitt. Das ist ja ganz verrückt. Viele Grüße an Melly, die hat's gemacht, auch wenn das jetzt für euch kein Kompliment war, aber ... Melly, erzähl mir mehr von Melly. Ja, Melly ist ... Moni oder Melly? Melly. Melanie, ne? Ich weiss nicht, ich kenne sie nur unter Melly. Melanie? Nein, Melitta. Melitta? Melly. Es ist einfach Melly. Okay. Ja, mit dem I, mit so einem Herz als I-Punkt. Mit dem y. Es tut mir leid. Erzähl mir mehr über Melly. Genau, die hat so grüne Haare, nur auch so Federohrringe, so tätowiert und die schneidet mir die Haare. Mit einem Taschenmesser. Mit einem Taschenmesser, das sie selber also geschnitzt hat im Wald, in der Waldhütte. Ich mag Melly. Bist du gerne im Wald? Ich bin sehr gerne im Wald, wirklich. Ja? Ich Wälder im Regen. Super gerne. Ohne Scheisse. Ich bin richtiger Naturmensch. Neulich habe ich mir für den Urlaub … Heidi! Ich wollte mich einfach mal in so eine einsame Hütte setzen und schreiben. Ja, das ist mega romantisch auch. So einen Poetry-Slam-Text vielleicht. Poetry-Slam, ein bisschen die Erde erleben, aber mich nicht zu sehr bewegen, weil ich faul bin. Aber ich glaube, ihr mögt das eigentlich, weil ihr geht da beide so drauf ab und habt das so drauf. Bei Airbnb habe ich eine Wohnung gefunden, ein Baumhaus, was irgendwer 15 Jahre lang gebaut hat, und zwar mitten auf den Azoren. Einfach die krasseste Umgebung, und dann mitten im Wald ist ein geiles Baumhaus, Meer durchdesignet, sieht unfassbar geil aus, aber halt leider teuer. Das ist halt das Problem, aber das wäre schon geil. 2000 Euro? Wäre das was für dich? Kriegen wir das hin? Vielen Dank, dass ihr das immer wieder ansprecht. Du hast nur 2000 Euro auf dem Konto gehabt, jemals. Heißt aber, dass du jetzt wahrscheinlich weniger hast. Vielleicht hat sie viele Konten. Oder sie hat eine Lüge. Oder es sind Schweizer Euros, die sind ja mehr wert als deutsche Euros. Hm. Ich möchte an dieser Stelle meine Mutter grüssen. Hi. Hallo Mama. Was möchtest du noch sagen? Wenn du jetzt mit deiner toten, fucking toten Ur-Uroma reden würdest, die so richtig tot ist, holy moly ist die tot, was würdest du dir jetzt mitgeben? Mitgeben oder fragen? Ne, fragen. Fragen? Ihr wisst ja nicht, wie nah ich gerade an diesem Thema dran bin. Ich war in mich auf Bali und ich war bei einer Leserin, bei einer Seherin, die mit toten Leuten geredet hat. Tatsächlich. Oh Gott. Wirklich, es war mega abgefahren. Also ich würde sie fragen, also wie war das genau mit den Nazis? Hattest du da was mit zu tun? Nein! Nein, meine Familie überhaupt nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Nein, wir wollen ja nicht darüber sprechen. Jetzt hör doch noch weiter, stell, stell eine andere Frage, was ist mit Klavier? Ja, also du hast ja Geld bekommen fürs Klavier und du bist, also anstatt das fürs Klavier auszugeben, hast du das einfach genommen und hast Party gemacht in den zwanziger Jahren. So ist das nicht ganz richtig. Woher kommen deine Fakten? Uuuuh, meine Fakten kommen von anderen Familienangehörigen. Kann das sein, dass die lügen? Ich frage dich jetzt. Die lügen! Ich wusste es! Das sind alles Juden. Ich wusste es! Also nicht im Nazi-Sinne, aber halt. Uuuuh, ich muss weg, tschau! Nein, bitte geh nicht! Nein! Du hast wirklich mit deinen, mit toten Leuten gesprochen, auf Bali? Ich wollte es nicht, aber ich kam halt ... Du warst mit Molly auf Bali und hast mit Gnadi gesprochen? Ich war alleine auf Bali. Und dann bin ich ... Ach Quatsch, erzähl mir doch nicht so eine Scheisse, als ob du alleine nach Bali fährst, mit 2000 Euro für Hundo Mello gehst du einfach schön nach Bali Letty oder was? Erzähl mir doch nichts. Du hast gefragt auf meinem Konto.
Du bist ein wildes Huhn, ich glaub es einfach nicht.
Bin ich zu dieser Frau gegangen, ich wusste gar nicht, was sie richtig macht. Und dann, es war so eine verrückte Australierin mit so tätowierten Augenbrauen und so grün stechenden Augen.
Und dann hat sie gesagt...
Es war ein Kaktus.
Es war ein Kaktus, es war kein Kaktus, ja. Das war eine ganz ernsthafte Begegnung. Und dann bin ich nur rein, ich bin nur in den Raum reingekommen und dann hat sie gesagt, somebody just passed away. Und dann hab ich gedacht so, how do you know, und dann hat sie gesagt, because she's here. Because it's written on your front. Woah, woah, woah, woah, langsam, langsam, langsam. Und du hast vor kurzem Mippen verloren? Was heisst vor kurzem? Dein Hamster. Oh nein, das ist total mies, ich war so ernste Themen. Was ist das für eine Scheisse gerade? Nee, aber was von, wie lange ist das her? Ja wirklich, äh, nicht lange, im März. Im März, jetzt ist es Juni, das sind fünf Monate. Ich war ja auch im Mai da. Okay. Jetzt überleg mal, es sind nur ein paar Wochen. Zwei Monate. Das sind nicht, Florian, ne? Ne, Florentin. Florentin. Oh, Entschuldigung, Flori. Flori, du Süsser. Ähm, doch nicht zwei Monate, es waren ja ein paar Wochen. Guck mal, April hat vier Wochen, dann sagen wir noch eine Woche vom März, äh, ihr doch, und eine Woche vom Mai sind sechs Wochen. Das sind ein paar Wochen. Ja, ich, das ist wirklich, just passed away, würde ich auch sagen. Kann sein, dass sie Facebook hat irgendwie und du das mal gepostet hast? Nein. Das ist ein Zauber.. Ja, soll ich dir widerlegen, dass sie nicht zaubern kann oder was? Nein, wieso? Du hast einfach so Skepsis hier. Naja, ich war sehr skeptisch, bin sehr skeptisch, aber das war einfach eine ganz krasse Erfahrung. Hat sie dir noch was gesagt? Ja, aber es möchte ich nicht hier fallen. Hast du noch gefallen, was hast du für ein T-Shirt angehabt? Dann möchte ich hier nicht, möchte hier nicht, möchte ich jetzt. Wie viele Finger zeige ich hinter meinem Rücken? Wo habe ich alles? Naja, ja, nein, möchte ich jetzt nicht weiter darauf eingehen. War das diese Karte? Ach man, ey, das ist aber ganz schön abgefahren. Das sind auch diese Tricks von diesem blöden Oma-Star. Aber was ist denn nur Wut plötzlich auf Hälsieher? Was ist denn da los? Ist ja offensichtlich ein armes Mädchen, was in Bali oder bei Europa... Weißt du, du bist einfach so fast zehn Jahre jünger als ich und das ist so... Jetzt ein junges armes Mädchen, was gebrochen gerade aus unserem Podcast kommt, was gerade jemanden verloren hat und dann kommt es nach Bali, will einfach nur schön sich mit dem Kokosnuss-Bikini schön an den Strand legen und ein bisschen Fun haben mit dem Bastrock und dann kommt plötzlich da so eine Oma vorbei und sagt dir, somebody just passed away und hier ist dein Pinacola, den du bestellt hast. Was für eine Scheisse. Ja, das ist echt eine Frage. Aber so war das ja gar nicht. So gesurft auch? Netter Gag, aber so was. Dafür hatte ich dann kein Geld mehr, ich habe stattdessen Yoga gemacht und meditiert. Ich habe mir die ganze Bandbreite gegeben. Und hat das funktioniert, meditieren? Ja oh Gott, ich hatte die mega schlimmste Erfahrung, wirklich, weil, also da hätte man Sketche drehen müssen. Ich war da ganz oft und dachte so, wo ist die Kamera, ich muss das alles filmen, ich muss das filmen. Wir waren in so einem grossen Raum und wir mussten uns alle natürlich auf im Schneidersitz hinsetzen und Händchen halten. Und dann war so ein indischer Guru und der hat dann erklärt, ja, wir atmen uns jetzt in Trance und das sind praktisch Drogen for free, die ihr hier kriegt und ich bin dabei, ich begleite das und habe keine Angst. Also wenn wir uns in Trance atmen, dann kommen alle Gefühle, die ihr unterdrückt, raus. Das kann sein in Form von Schreien, in Form von Lachen, in Form von Wein, manche haben sogar Orgasmen, das ist aber selten in Form von Möbel. Lasst alles raus. Manche geben ihr Geld, manche Geld, das war doch ein Euro, je nachdem wie viel sie haben, oder? Und da mussten wir uns so reinatmen und dann war halt ein, es waren halt alles so, so Fake-Hippies oder Möchtegern-Hippies, so aus aller Welt, ne, ich war auch die einzige Deutsche und es war halt ein Mann im Hawaii-Hemd, der war so Mitte fünfzig. Jürgen von der Lippe. Nein, also es war krass und wir haben gerade erst mal angefangen, also der konnte einfach noch nicht in Trance sein, der konnte noch nicht in Trance sein, wir hatten halt alle die Augen zu, weil wir mussten auch auf unsere Chakren und drittes Auge und so. Und ich hör nur aus seiner Ecke auf einmal so, ah, ah, ah, und ich glaub so, Gott, der hat einen epileptischen Arsch von Scheisse, wieso hilft ihm keiner? Und dann hat er aber weitergemacht und immer so, Jesus Christ, ah, und dann fing aus der anderen Ecke eine Frau an die ganze Zeit so, aber nicht so ein Tränchenwein, sondern so richtig. Und neben mir fing einer an zu lachen, es war mega abgefahren und ich war richtig abgefuckt, weil mich das so aggressiv gemacht hat. Und dann waren wir fertig mit der Meditation, er kam dann auch währenddessen rum und hat einem so Kraft über den Kopf gegeben und so und hat gefragt, ja, wie waren denn eure Erfahrungen und eure Erlebnisse, lasst uns das jetzt hier alle noch zusammen teilen und dann fingen diese ganzen Yogis an und haben gesagt so, erst mal, you are all amazing, thank you very much, thank you, wow, that was magic, thank you. Und dann habe ich gedacht so, ich möchte jetzt auch was sagen und habe gesagt, also, das ist jetzt meine erste Meditation, aber ich möchte ganz kurz sagen, das hat mich irgendwie aggressiv gemacht, diese Geräusche und es hat mich auch ehrlich gesagt…
Dass sie alle die Fresse nicht halten können. Habe ich gesagt! Und das in einem Kreis von Hippies zu sagen, ist das Schlimmste, was man sagen kann. Es waren so Blicke von entweder so, ja danke, endlich sagt jemand die Wahrheit oder so, die ist noch ganz am Anfang, da ist noch so ein Prozessform, ja? Die hat noch so viel Wut in sich. Die hat noch sehr, da ist noch echt ganz viele Blockaden zu lösen. Und er hat dann aber zu mir gesagt, ja, komm morgen wieder, danke, dass du so ehrlich bist, aber wenn was in dir ist, das dich nervt, dann ist da was in dir, was dir als Kind passiert ist, weil alles, was du spürst, das hat was mit dir zu tun, nicht mit den anderen und komm morgen wieder. Und dann dachte ich, natürlich komme ich morgen wieder, diese Blöße gebe ich mir nicht. Da bin ich am nächsten Tag wieder hingegangen und dann dachte ich, wenn wir das Spiel spielen, ich bin Schauspielerin, Leute, spiele ich mit und dann habe ich geschrien. Und dann habe ich einfach alles geschrien und dachte, und danach haben wir wieder so eine Runde gemacht und jeder hat seine Meinung gesagt und dann hat so ein Typ gesagt, wieder das gleiche, danke, all amazing, wow. Und ich habe da eine gehört, die so schlimm geschrien hat und es tat mir echt leid, was du erlebt hast und ich wollte nur sagen, ich schicke dir all meine positive Energie. Und danke, dass das so möglich war. Du hast das Lügen, wow. Aber Respekt durch Lügen, so viel positive Energie zu bekommen, ist auch nett, du hast sehr viel positive Energie abgegriffen. Aber du hast nichts Echtes gespürt während der Meditation. Naja, ich kann mich ja in alles reinsteigern, mir alles, ich bin ja, du kannst mir alles sagen, ich bin Kaninchen, denke ich auch irgendwann, ich bin Kaninchen. Ja, aber jetzt mal wirklich so, dass irgendwo, dass wirklich das passiert. Na, ich habe mich aber danach komischerweise wirklich besser gefühlt, weil man ja einfach nie schreien darf. Und das ist ja einfach, das ist ja das gleiche wie mit Theaterspielen, ich kann jetzt nicht auf der Straße sagen, ich möchte eine Biene sein, so, und das macht einfach Spaß. Ja, ich habe mich danach besser gefühlt. Ist Biene das erste, was dir eingefallen ist gerade? Ja. Geil, wir beide lieben Bienen. What? Ich glaube, das ist aber einfach so ein Selbstzweck. Ich glaube, wenn du da nochmal hingehst, dann fackst du es nochmal und irgendwann, also wenn immer aus dieser Gruppe immer die Hälfte der Gruppe geht und eine neue Gruppe kommt und die faken dann die anderen so lange an, bis sie auch denken, okay, ich muss es auch faken, und dann wird dieser Fake-Gedanke immer weitergeführt, ohne dass jetzt wirklich da was Echtes dahin ist. Also ich kann mich damit nicht aus, das müssen wir mal ausprobieren. Aber geil, dass wir so in ihrer Welt sind, dass wenn jemand das komplett abstösst, die sagen, ja, das ist jetzt, das ist diese Energie. Das ist genau das, was wir gerade bekämpfen wollen. Du kommst da nicht raus eigentlich. Das ist so eine ganz fiese Spirale, die wir einerschieben. Ja, es war auch wirklich so ein Baumhaus im Dschungel, alles offen. Geil. Und dann gab es abends auch so Ecstatic Dance, da ist dann jeder hingegangen und dann hat man einfach so frei und wild getanzt und alle waren schweissnass und Dschungel und … Bist du eher ein Arm oder ein Beintänzer? Na, da machst du natürlich alles. Da rollst du dich über … da machst du einfach alles. Alles. Zu welcher Musik? Was hört man da so? Codnight Joe oder was wird da so aufgelegt? Nein, ihr habt ja gar keine Ahnung. Nee, schon so Elektro. Ach so. Echt jetzt? Elektro am Bali-Strand? Nicht, also im Dschungel, Mann! Welcher Elektro? Entschuldigung, ich war so in Trance, da kann ich mich jetzt echt nicht daran erinnern. Wirklich nicht. Ja, aber ist es denn so Berlin-Mitte oder ist es Scooter oder ist es so Strand oder was ist das? Nein, es war wirklich echt schöne Musik. Es war sehr schöne Musik. Okay. Viel auch Narko Beer, glaube ich, wenn man, den kann man googeln, wenn man will. Narko Beer. Ja, der habe ich ein Konzert gesehen auch. Geil. So, das zu mir soweit. Ich will mich nur ausdenklichen. Stefan, ja, ist toll, es hat was irgendwie so diese Excellen von Baden. Mich will ich ausdenklichen. Auch wie das sehe, jetzt mit so einer beruhigenden Stimme. Ich finde es ganz schön, wenn man sieht, dass man auch irgendwie auch mit 2000 Euro ein tolles Leben führen kann, das einen irgendwie auf eine innere Mitte, auf eine spirituelle Höhe wirft. Also irgendwann hört es halt auf, lustig zu sein, ne? Also immer wieder auf den gleichen Punkt. Aber die Frau, also die meinte auch, dass ich jetzt bald ganz reich werde. Ja, weil wir jetzt aus Mitleid sehr viel Geld geben werden gleich im Ausgang. Also ich würde mal sagen, Leute, wenn ihr diese nette junge Dame, die ihr gerade gehört habt, unterstützen wollt, dann geht auf geht auf patreon.com slash podcast ufup, was Stefan leider falsch geschrieben hat, und spendet ein bisschen Geld für uns und da können wir dann sie vom Kaffee trinken einladen. Wir leuten sie mal ein bisschen weiter. Trink doch keinen Kaffee. Ein Euro davon geht ein guter Zweck. Ja, oder wir köpfen ein schönes Bierchen oder ein Sektlein oder ein Kümmerling oder sowas und da machen wir uns einen schönen Abend, okay? Ist das was? Ja, danke,ie, danke schön. Na, das ist doch was. Ist der schönste Tag in meinem Leben. Wunderbar. Wenn man nicht live sehen will, wo kann man das tun? Alles klar. Hast du eine Website? Lena Kupke dot org. Ich hab so eine peinliche Facebook-Seite mit 100 Likes. Wie heisst sie? Lena Kupke, so wie ich hee. Ach so, ich dachte wegen peinlicher Name oder so.
Nein, Lena K-U-P-K-E.
Gut, dann schaut alle mal auf Facebook vorbei, es lohnt sich.
Lass den Leid.
Junge ausschrebende junge Dame.
Und vielen Dank, dass du da warst.
Gerne, vielen Dank, dass ich hier sein durfte.
Ja, immer gerne.
Und ansonsten wünschen wir euch der Tüger umschiede Woche.
Danke auch an Florin.
Vielen Dank an Stefan.
Danke, danke.
Vielen besonderen Dank an mich.
Und ich würde sagen, wir sind ja ein UFO, deswegen heben wir jetzt ab.